let's pull up this smear oh boy forbes
publishes an article titled dave rubin
is being rejected by his own audience
all right all right well a lot of people
have criticism criticisms of dave rubin
but um
i don't think this headline actually
fits what is being accused of dave rubin
it's the weirdest it's clearly a lie and
this is once again the game being played
the story is i'll simplify it and then
we'll go through it dave rubin and his
husband are having two children through
surrogacy prominent christian
conservatives say i disagree with gay
marriage and i disagree with birth
through surrogacy therefore you know
we'll will issue statements of criticism
towards dave rubin
that's very very different from saying
that his own audience has turned against
him because like a handful of public
figures who are christian conservatives
are having conversations with him where
they say they disagree and they don't
like his lifestyle you know if his
audience turned against him you'd expect
like
he's losing millions of subscribers or
you know tens of thousands he's getting
disliked like crazy and that's not
happening so here here's the point of
this article in my opinion they've not
written an article to inform anyone of
anything they've written an article to
just rile up people who already hate
dave rubin so they can be like haha i
was right the whole time dave rubin's a
bad person
there's there's i i don't genuinely know
like if anything is to be gained by
media doing things like this and so you
know i'll do a throwback when you said
that twitter is just you know negative
impulses i think that's where the
entirety of the media is at well if i
read forbes's own description of
themself the first reaction that i have
to this before i even care about the
story is they say forbes is a global
media company focusing on business
investment technology entrepreneurship
and leadership
and like you're writing about a dude
that decided to have a kid while he's
gay with a husband yeah that's right
slow news day i mean yeah why do i i
don't care i mean there's why
yeah maybe maybe what we do there's a
lot of money to be made in making people
think the world is worse than it is the
world is more divided than it is and we
hate each other more than we do and i
think everybody's looking to get in on
it as much as humanly possible and i
find it disgusting not everybody but
enough people are that it's raising an
alarm bell i don't i i would say there
are certainly the grifters as we call
them who want to get in on it i wonder
if also people are genuinely just in
that world and it's making it worse and
it's making it more pronounced so the
more stories like this come out the more
people get riled up the more they talk
about it i genuinely think there are a
lot of people on the left who truly
believe what they're saying and every
day they come out saying you know the
republicans are worse than the nazis or
whatever i think they really believe it
i think they're they justified in their
own minds i certainly think there are
people on the right who do the same to
the left however i think the tendency on
the right is they tend to know what the
left is thinking so they have a more
balanced view of what the culture war
actually is and the left just keeps one
up one-upping everything and getting
more and more absurd
yeah that's definitely true and i think
one of the things that i have observed
with the right is that people say oh um
well one of the things i've noticed at
the right is constantly more well versed
in what the left thinks than the left is
and what the right things because we are
constantly exposed to what the left
believes because as i said earlier the
left is in charge of the institutions
especially journalism and that's why i
think that such a majority of twitter is
so left-leaning is because most of them
are journalists how do you define that
though i mean when i hear somebody say
the left that could be almost anything
from michael bloomberg to vosh i mean
that's a very very large spectrum it
does include it is a spectrum yeah for
sure so so the challenge when having
conversations actually someone super
chatted this they said there's no middle
ground there's only uninformed people or
something like that and so the issue is
i would disagree i think that person
probably has 40 different things that
they
most likely down a checklist like this
this this this and if somebody disagrees
with them on one of them it depends on
where you're where you're at right if so
if you're an economic left on like
healthcare and you go to a healthcare
convention where there's like a bunch of
conservatives talking and you're arguing
for universal healthcare they're going
to call you a leftist you know what i
mean
so if it depends on which issue you're
particular you're specifically on yeah
but uh to back to my earlier point
though
uh the point i made earlier
if you're in the middle genuinely and
you stand up and speak out you're
instantly right-wing so for instance
these uh the reason the ncaa swimmers
won't speak up about the biological male
in the competition is because as they've
stated privately they're scared they'll
be ostracized or kicked out and won't be
able to compete or they'll lose all
their career opportunities they'll be
kicked out of school or generally just
have their life ruined
these are people who are in the middle i
mean these these are these are people
who are not
pronounced uh you know
one way or the other who can't say a
word because they'll be called far right
if someone if i want to give a speech
and someone start calling me a name like
hey rightist hey you're far left hey
you're a centrist
i would see that as them deflecting what
i'm talking about avoiding the
conversation it's just kind of like a
placation it doesn't it doesn't
people try to figure out who you are so
they could figure out whether they
should dismiss your beliefs without
engaging with them
what a crazy world we live in yeah i
understand that you do want to discern
like i don't want to go smell the poop
to know that it stinks i already know it
stinks so like i don't need to know
every piece of poop to know that poop
sticks covered for me was one of the
best examples that there was very that
there was somewhat diminishing middle
ground in public discourse like for
instance i'll get all of these comments
that say you know the reason that this
stuff still exists is because idiots
like you were wearing a mask in the
beginning the more you if you comply you
will never stop it's like i had people
in the store were wearing masks back
when the television told us that you
were a hypochondriac if you did that
right we did that because i told them
very clearly if everybody gets sick at
the same time payroll here is twenty
thousand dollars a week rent is twelve
thousand a month uh here's how much
money is in the bank here's how much i
can afford to pay you all if you all get
sick and we don't have any money so
everybody decide to wear one uh you know
just just just if because we didn't know
what the hell was going on yet so let's
just stay safe but i didn't close my
business i'm not going to close my
business and just you know not make
anything for that entire time and just
economically destroy myself so people
who were a little bit more left would
say you know you're i got hate mail
under my door for april of 2020 like
consistently
for being open yeah because i was
staying there to finish the shipping
because the shipping person and the
the receptionist were staying home so i
was doing the job of both so i would
stay a little late and i would go to the
bathroom after closing the lights and
come back and i'd see hate mailed to my
door after eight but there was a you
know they would say how dare you or some
evil capital is staying open and then
people that were on the right would say
you know you [ __ ] why are you wearing a
mask and it's like i mean i'm not saying
that you should have to close your
business i'm not saying that you should
have to close your business but uh but
i'm gonna do the basic things that i can
do just to
if there's any chance of it increasing
my likelihood of surviving and
increasing likely to the business
surviving why not and it's like it was
just one or the other from so many
people and it was very boring so the
person who said there's no middle ground
i think there is middle ground like even
on an issue like covet i am not going to
say it it's usually either this doesn't
exist this is a hoax you're an idiot or
be afraid until 2030. and it's like
there is a middle ground of i will live
my life here are the minor modifications
i will make that don't have a cost here
are the modifications that have a great
cost that i'm not willing to make and i
you know i weigh it and i do it that way
but is the middle ground having an
impact on policy
is the middle ground having an impact on
policy yeah i think the answer is no
well i did see the cbs has did an
article about hunter biden's laptop it's
on cbs now i think that us being kind of
a middle ground i feel like a middle
ground force pushing this hunter biden
thing it's it's broken through it's
affecting policy only after it doesn't
matter it's possible right
it doesn't matter i mean just to get
that knowledge out into the mainstream
is important because it may in 2024
ended up being a bigger deal than we
realize
yeah yeah maybe but um
i wonder if that has anything to do with
the middle ground i mean the the
conversation on 100 laptop needed to
happen in october and it was shut down
by big tech in the in the corporate
press i don't think the middle ground
has as much of a of an effect on policy
if it did again in new york uh you had
mass mandates business closures and
everything else in other states they're
saying if you want some if you let's say
if you ask the schools to make people
wear mass you know we're not going to
give you money so it's literally one way
or the other
it's not it's the the radicals on each
side that have that have an effect on
policy but see so here's the issue i
take with that is if uh in florida they
say schools can't require masks that's
the government telling the government it
has restrictions if the government tells
a private individual they can't open
their business that's the government
imposing on private individuals one's
bad one's government restriction i would
rather err on the florida side than the
new york side just to make it obvious
but uh i didn't even know if our that
order applied to repair shops because
they actually edited it on march 20th
2020 when cuomo did the pause order it
read as if the only places that can stay
open are places that are doing
technology repair for the government and
then they edited the website to make it
sound like it was anybody that is doing
technology repair but i still stayed
open i would er on the side of florida
before the side of new york the other
thing is in terms of the coveted
response at the governmental level the
left would say like oh trump's failures
or the republicans failures led to
ex-deaths whereas you had you know cuomo
wolf you had um what's his face in new
jersey what was it what was it murphy
murphy yeah you had um uh um
man whitmer you had whitmer and and who
else did it who else was the other
governor some i think uh illinois
government
did it these are the they they all
literally murdered people right yeah
right so they so during covet they
actually
with knowledge put covet patience in
nursing homes resulting in mass death
right cuomo for instance was warned by
like his his chief of health or whatever
if you put sick people in nursing homes
you will kill people it doesn't strike
me as the type of person that likes to
be told no by anybody but so think about
what that means i mean on the right it's
like we're not going to the government
will not intervene but then people will
die if you don't well you know it's your
responsibility to figure out for
yourself the government's not going to
impose on the private establishments
though they you know they do for to a
follow-up reason this in this instance
they were you know limited and then
in all of these big democrat
governorship states they were like i
mean we'll literally kill people like
they didn't have to you know in new york
they had the javits center they could
have put sick people in the java center
only reached 30 capacity they used that
they i think then they have the us army
corps of engineers built a hospital in
the java center they did and it was it
was at 30 capacity but instead of
putting patients there cuomo said you
know he'd rather just kill elderly
people in nursing homes i know they sent
the uss comfort but there were a lot of
complaints saying that they were not
allowed to take a bunch of different
patients so it kind of wound up they
claimed it was more of a pr stunt for
trump than it was actually helping i
only read one article on that so i'm not
as well informed but i know that the
javits center was supposed to be built
to be
a hospital yeah and it wasn't it wasn't
used like i mean 30 i think was the was
as
high as it got yeah and then 70 of the
real estate that city probably isn't
even used maybe they could have built a
lot so so you know therein lies the main
point if you know once again back to the
what we're talking about if you go to
the middle and ask them they'd say
put the sick people in the javits center
but the democratic establishment was
like no kill kill the elderly in the
nursing homes and it was done in like
five different states was that the
democratic establishment or was that
cuomo being a dumbass that if it was
just cuomo then you would have seen it
with whitmer murphy wolf and newsom
all of these different democrat
governors all doing the same thing did
they all have a nursing home scandal
because i didn't follow every other
state the only thing i know about winter
was the walmart thing where you're
allowed to go into aisle 11 but not
thirteen right yeah let's let's triple
check though you wanna you can you wanna
pull that up i'm pretty sure they all
did the same thing yeah i believe so and
in fact one yeah yeah and in
pennsylvania it was rachel levine the
transgender admiral she took her mother
out and took their their parents out of
the nursing home before they did it
right so i mean they knew what they were
doing well one of our friends charlie
lee duff is actually suing governor
whitmer over this stuff right yeah so i
know what happened there and it wasn't
as big a scandal as it was with cuomo
but it was a very real problem for them
it was like almost like yeah
from the cuomo thing but it is a big
deal yeah you got it too
so so
all of these governors did the same
thing and the people at the highest
level knew what was going on clearly now
it's possible it wasn't coordinated but
that they were at least communicating as
to what was happening with each other
and taking actions meanwhile regular
people were seeing their parents die in
nursing homes so again you go to an
average person in the middle and they'll
be like hey this is really really bad
but if you come out and say the things
we're saying right now they'll call you
right wing thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you